much like in the real world if you
really want to make a name for yourself
in Hyrule it's going to take money
Moolah Cold Hard Cash well rupees in
this case thankfully unlike the real
world there are Bountiful opportunities
to rake in enough funds to not only help
you survive but Thrive there are also
several other currencies in the game
that can be traded in for other items
and upgrades that you may not have even
noticed are in your inventory here are
all the best tips for gaining rupees as
well as other currencies in tears of the
Kingdom as well as the places to spend
them and just so you are aware there are
slight spoilers in this video for places
that you can go and NPCs you can meet in
the game
when you come across Addison the loyal
employee of Hudson construction helping
him hold up the sign for his employer by
creating a brace will not only net you
some food but a red rupee worth 20
rupees bloopies that are found near the
entrances to caves can be attacked to
drop rupees the best way to do this as
they can be easily spooked is with a bow
subsequent hits will net you more money
they cannot be caught and they cannot be
killed and while they will eventually
run off into the nearest cave they do
respawn over time facing off against the
yiga whether in their bases in the
depths or by getting caught in their
Mighty banana traps will always net you
rupees if you manage to best them in
combat if there are materials you're
finding that you rarely if ever utilize
don't worry about trading them into
vendors for rupees in return there's
always materials to scavenge in the
world if you ever do find yourself
needing a specific item if you have any
amiibo you can also scan them once a day
to drop some extra materials however
hold on to your gems until you run into
the NPC remella who is found in Goron
City she'll ask you to sell your gems to
her topaz's rubies and the like but
these need to be done in bulk are prices
tend to be 20 better compared to most
vendors however Eventide island is in
the Southeastern corner of the map head
to the top and you'll find two
researchers who want to test out their
Zone eye plane and they'll pay you if
you Aid them you'll want to make it
lands dead center of the Target location
all without falling off if you do it
right the researchers will be happy each
challenge attempt costs 20 rupees but
since you'll earn 100 rupees for a near
Perfect Landing you should have 80
rupees each time there are several other
side quests that will net you rupees
including the potential princess
sightings questline which can be started
from the lucky clover Gazette outside to
a village as well as the messages from
an ancient era quest line that can be
started by speaking with the man staring
at the Fallen monolith in Lookout
Landing after that anytime you run into
a monolith in the sky portion of the
game take a snapshot with the poorer pad
and showing him the pictures will net
you 100 rupees each time selling meals
to any vendor with high quality meat
will net you a bunch of rupees and is
one of the best repeatable ways to make
money in the game to Banff the tundra in
the Northwest is host to a lot of the
animals that can provide that grade of
meat such as moose wolves and foxes so
whenever you need to make money fast
this is the most reliable method however
in order for those animals to be present
in that area you will need to deal with
its Regional phenomena first zonite is
the material that is used as a currency
to upgrade your energy cell the thing
that powers your zonai devices in your
Creations as such the energy cell is
just as important as upgrading your
health and stamina zonaids can be
discovered in abundance in the depths
the underground portion of Hyrule as
well as the great Sky Island any
crystallized rock formations that glue
green will drop zoneite when broken
apart by a heavy weapon monsters
infected with Gloom in the depths will
also drop zoneite zoonites can be taken
to forges in order to be processed into
either zonai charges or crystallized
charges while one Forge can be found in
the great Sky Island the other four are
found exclusively in the depths the
forges in the depths are able to pump
out way more zonai and crystallized
charges than the one in the great Sky
Island one zonai charge costs two zonite
and one crystallized charge costs three
zonite zonai charges can be used at the
various dispensers in the sky islands to
get more zonite devices in your
inventory they can also be consumed to
replenish your energy cells charge
crystallized charges can be used for
gaining additional batteries for your
energy cell each well in a battery costs
100 crystallized charges so you'll need
300 crystallized charges for a whole
battery you can also discover large
zoneite three of which can be traded in
for a large crystallized charge worth 20
regular crystallized charges which means
you only need five of them to upgrade
the energy cell you can also gain two
huge crystallized charges in the game by
defeating Master Koga the leader of the
yiga clan once in the great abandoned
Central mine during the mystery of the
depths Mainline quests and the other
time in the abandoned grudo mine as part
of the master Koga of the yiga clan side
quest huge crystallized charges are
worth 100 regular crystallized charges
so turning them both in will net you two
additional wells in your energy cell
needless to say if you want to upgrade
your energy cell to build all the wild
zonai Contraptions you see on social
media including the Dropship are Zelda
expert Max built which consists of a
flying drone that deploys a land drone
and a guide for which we have on
Gamespot you're going to need to spend a
ton of time farming in the depths bubble
gems are snowflake looking materials
that can be harvested by defeating
bubble frogs which can be found in caves
all over Hyrule bubble gems can be
handed over to Colton who you can find
initially at the Woodland Stables in
Eldon speak to his brother kilton also
located there who will initiate the side
quest to hand over the gem once you
trade in your first bubble gem for a
bakoblin mask which will make it hard
for the Goblins to spot you Colton will
move to another location you need to
find kilton first who has relocated to
Tarrytown in the Northeast he will give
you the quest marker to find Colton once
you find Colton he will appear in that
spot anytime after 9pm in the game
trading three bubble gems will net you a
new reward with some armor exclusively
available through him
Pony points are acquired by interacting
with any of the Stables littered around
Hyrule Pony points can be spent at The
Ledger in any stable in return for
rewards such as improved Saddles and the
ability to register additional horses
these activities will net you one pony
Point each visiting a new stable
registering a horse every time you sleep
at a stable some Stables have NPCs that
will give you side quests that can also
net you Pony points korok seeds can be
obtained anytime you find a korok in the
game there are literally hundreds of
them and they can be uncovered in
numerous ways when you run into a korok
that needs help reaching their friend
you can use ultra hands to Aid them
these interactions will net you two
Clorox seeds every time Clorox seeds can
be given to hesitu in return for gaining
more inventory slots hestu can be first
found near Serene stable on the way to
Rito Village when here if you defeat the
trees that are terrorizing him he will
allow you up to two expansions to your
inventory before moving on hestu
actually goes to Lookout Landing next
speak to him there for additional
inventory slots as you gain Clorox seeds
hestu will remain in Lookout Landing
until you enter korok Forest where he
will ultimately reside
pose are little blue flames that can be
found all over the place in the depths
pushes can be traded in at Josh's
Workshop under pura's Lab at Lookout
Landing by speaking to the bargainer
statue the bargainer Statue has some
exclusive items and armor that make it
easier to survive the depths
Sage's Wills can be found predominantly
In The Sky Islands across Hyrule they
are the most limited of all the
currencies in the game they could be
traded in at the same goddess statues
that you speak to in order to turn light
of blessings into hearts and stamina
once you've completed each of the four
Regional phenomena you'll be able to
call upon avatars of the sages connected
to each of those events trading in four
sages Wills will allow you to upgrade
the attack power of an avatar
those are all the different currencies
you can find in the game if you found
this guide helpful make sure to like And
subscribe and stay tuned to Gamespot for
a bunch more tears of the Kingdom
content
[Music]